[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une équipe expérimentée et
compétente puisqu'elle regroupe la
majorité des adjoints et conseillers
municipaux actuels néanmoins c'est une
liste que j'ai voulu largement
renouvelée afin de dynamiser sur de
nouvelles actions
c'est une liste aussi que j'ai voulu
diversifier pour agir au nom de toutes
les générations tous les quartiers et
enfin c'est pour l'ensemble de ces
raisons que nous avons également obtenu
les soutiens majeurs que sont ceux de
madame la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse du président du
département ainsi que du président de
notre agglomération saint-quentin divine
et de madame claude berger maire de
plaisir difficile de donner un seul
point phare parmi 140 engagement
distillées sur 13 thèmes sachant que
notre objectif général et le mieux vivre
ensemble une maison pluridisciplinaire
de santé qui était un de nos objectifs
annoncés dès le début de la campagne
c'est à dire il y a un an
un volet très important ce tout ce qui
est écouté et démocratie participative
est enfin très important aussi pour la
vie locale
un partenariat très actif avec nos
commerçants locaux et pour terminer un
volet de sécurité et de prévention
[Applaudissements]
ma première décision en tant que maire
sera de faire voter le budget avec pour
la dixième année consécutive un maintien
des taux de fiscalité locale
cet objectif est de permettre de lancer
simultanément toutes les actions
nécessaires est prioritaire suite à la
crise que nous venons venir avec tous
les impacts sociaux et par exemple la
création d'une délégation à l'emploi la
création d'une délégation à la santé et
la création d'une délégation à la
transition écologique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]